All right. Welcome, Mahault. This will
be the final of the presentation
sessions in the symposium. This is
Mahault Abu Rasin with the presentation
shared pretensions in active inference.
So, thank you, Mahault, to you.
And you're the first to join with an
Aiststute guardian.
Awesome. Shall I share my screen? Yes.
Let'S do. Just a second.
I'm looking for a window. I think this
will do. Okay, so can you
see the screen? Yes. Looks good. Thank
you. Awesome. So,
unfortunately, I imagine
that you are seeing the entire
screen and not just the presentation. I
apologize about that. I got it. It's
cropped. I got it. Okay, wonderful.
Thank you. All right,
so welcome to the presentation on Shared
Potential under Active Inference. We're
going to cover a lot of topics.
Shall I introduce myself a little bit,
or have you already done that?
Awesome. So, my name is Mawal Bahasa.
I'm a PhD student in cognitive
computing. I work in active inference in
the interaction between social sciences,
philosophy, consciousness, science, and
artificial intelligence. We're going to
start a presentation on potential and
active inference. So I'm going to define
a lot of terms. It's going to deal into
philosophy, terms that are very deep.
And so let's get started. If you will
just give me one small second.
And we're back. So, shared potential is
a term derived from phenomenology, and
it refers to the shared anticipation of
future events among a group of
individuals. This philosophical study of
experience and consciousness becomes
particularly interesting when we
consider it in the context of active
inference. When we combine these two
concepts, we get a powerful tool for
understanding how groups of individuals
can coordinate their actions and work
towards a common goal. This is the main
focus of the discussion today. So
imagine a group of people planning
a trip. They all share a common goal to
have a successful and enjoyable trip.
This shared goal forms the basis of
their shared potential. They all
anticipate future events related to the
trip, such as booking tickets, packing
their bags, and visiting various
attractions. As they start to take
actions towards their goal, they're also
engaging in active inference. They're
making predictions about what will
happen next and then adjusting these
predictions based on what actually
happens. So, for example, they might
predict that a certain flight will be
the cheapest based on their past
experiences. But when they actually
check the prices, they find that another
flight is cheaper. So they adjust their
prediction and book the other flight.
This constant cycle of prediction and
adjustment, guided by their shared
potential, helps the group coordinate
their actions and make their trip a
success. So we're going to delve deeper
into the concepts and explore the role
of past experiences known as retentions
in shaping our current knowledge and
future predictions.
Let's explain first the concept of
retentions. Retention is a key component
of time consciousness that retains the
past trajectory of a temporal object.
It's the preservation of the content of
a now past hyletic datum in our
present consciousness. A highletic datum
refers to the raw,
uninterpreted sensations that arise in
our consciousness. When we retain these
data, we are essentially keeping a
record of past sensations and
experiences that can inform our present
and our future actions.
In active inference, we can formalize
retention by thinking of moments as
binning of states which are bound to a
hierarchical state. This way, retention
is seen as the bidding which becomes the
current state, informing the next
expected state. To further connect
retention with active inference, we can
consider the way in which retention
plays a role in updating an agent's
belief and generative model. The past
experiences influence the current
expectations and actions, thus shaping
the agent's understanding of the world
and the future. So let's consider
a practical example to illustrate this
concept. If you had a good experience at
a particular restaurant, you might
choose to go there again in the future.
Your past experience influences your
future decision. In hostile temporal
phenomenology, we would think about much
shorter timescale. But if we extend this
concept, we can see a much larger
structure wherein the retention is
simply the past state. It's like having
a mental note that says this place is
good. And this is how an example of
retention works in your everyday life.
They're not merely representation or
memories, but presentations of a
temporarily extended present which
distinguishes them from recollections.
This involves the presentation of some
already constituted content in conscious
experience. Retentions also play a
crucial role in mapping past knowledge
onto current beliefs, contributing to
the development of shared narratives or
goals that we will delve into in the
rest of the presentation. They can
be former now points and the current
awareness of the past and far.
Sedimented retentions can be engraved in
scripts or deep temporal priors or more
fluid deontic cues. This phenomenon
corresponds to a specific application of
message passing between agents in the
present moment and in the sensorium.
Retentions and protensions may also
emerge jointly within a group, forming a
collective understanding that transcends
individual perspectives.
Protensions, as we saw,
refer to the anticipation of future
events based on past experiences and
current knowledge. It's thus forward
looking. It's the forward looking
counterpart to retention which is
backward looking. Retention is the
anticipation of future trajectories of a
temporal object. It's the process of
looking ahead, predicting what's to come
based on what has been and what
currently is. So in active inference,
it could be formalized by considering
the future states that are expected
based on the current state and past
states. Protension is thus the
anticipation guiding the next action.
We can consider the way in which
protension plays a role in updating an
agent's beliefs and generative models
influencing the actions and thus shaping
the agent's understanding of the world
and the future. So for instance, if you
see Dark Cloud in the sky, you might
anticipate that it's going to rain and
decide to carry an umbrella. This
anticipation of future events is
potential. It's also going to determine
whether or not you're wet when you go
outside and therefore whether or not you
expect to be wet. Your brain is
constantly making predictions about
what's going to happen next. So let's
put this in the context of temporal flow
which ties together those concepts of
primal impressions and we will see
retention and protention.
Temporal flow is the structure that
represents the continuous progression of
time from the past through the present
and into the future.
Agents are constantly revising their
generative models and they do this by
integrating the observations which we
could refer to here as primal
impressions. This updating process
is a balancing act between maintaining
the predictive density of the agent's
current beliefs and adapting to new
information. Retentions and pretensions
structure time for a given agent
creating a framework that shapes their
perception and anticipation.
Different agents or systems will exhibit
varying qualities and quantities of
retention and potential which resembles
something like Mike Levin's concept of
cognitive light codes. So given the
presence of retention we can anticipate
a protentional horizon not merely as
an arbitrary expectation.
Are thus the point at which agents
beliefs about the world are updated to
match their current observations which
leads to a more accurate understanding
of the environment and allows for more
effective goal directed behavior.
Primal impressions are the fulfillment
of a potential which is the time bound
nexus of perception and existence.
It is the resolved probability that
redefines the local gradient.
It's in primal impression that reality
collapses. The primal impression is thus
modeled as the essential Bayesian
cognitive moment. It is the
juxtaposition of prior beliefs or
retention with ongoing sensory
information in an unfolding future
oriented present or retention.
So now we have a description of temporal
thickness from feminine ominnology which
is compatible with generative modeling
and active inference agents for
hospital. This flow of conscious
experience is primarily made up of
sensations that well up in a raw
uninterpreted form that we called
earlier hyletic data. So this data is
the now phase of a temporal object. It
is formatted according to the identic or
cognitive laws of consciousness. This is
specifically relative to inner time.
We can understand how temporal flow
structures how agents are able to make
choices, act to self evidence, connect
the passive structure with the active
component of decision making or goal
pursuit. Individuals have drives and
teleology insofar as they have
preferences. These preferences are
protented goals reached towards by
what we would call potentially the fiat
wherein the fiat constitutes the will to
act towards a desire. So the fulfillment
of a pretension by fiat drives the agent
towards a teleology across a trail set
in a retentional extension. More
information is amassed. So the longer
your retention, more information can be
caught in a moment. As individuals amass
enough information they can then find a
structure to the information which
becomes a map rather than a territory
and is computationally more efficient
than the sum of all the information
amassed. This new state
of information may lead individuals
closer to a shared goal. The information
amassed turns into an emergent whole of
the retention, which grabs focus
at the present moment because it seems
to bring signals to the model that the
potential goal is closer and is
computationally simpler to retain.
So sharing of retentions and potentials
among group members in a social context
can facilitate coordination and the
achievement of a shared goal.
By aligning their beliefs about the past
or retentions and expectations about the
future or potentials, group members can
better predict each other's actions and
intentions. This allows them to work
together more effectively.
In some cases, group members may have
retentions and potentials that align
naturally due to common experiences or
understanding. Even without active
communication, however, group members
often actively communicate their
retentions and protensions, aligning
their beliefs and expectations through
dialogue and interaction,
thereby enhancing their ability to
predict each other's actions and
intentions. Retentions and protensions
may also emerge jointly within the
group, not confined to any individual
agents, unvelt forming a collective
understanding that transcends individual
perspectives. This complex
interplay of individual and collective
dynamics can be explored further in
hierarchical generative models
encompassing resonant, cognitive models,
communication and even joint emergence.
The structure of time consciousness
encapsulated in retention and protension
thus plays a significant role in the
emergence of shared potentials.
As agents retain and process similar
elements from their environment, they
can cocompute shared potentials by
mapping each other's cognitive pathways
and building upon one another's trails.
This process is formalized by Bayesian
updating the relationship between the
topology of protensions and the
expectation gradient, as well as the
role of retention in mapping past
knowledge on the current beliefs plays a
role in development of shared narratives
and goals.
We can use this to get a deeper insight
into the processes that drive the
emergence of collective behavior and the
development of shared understanding
among agents. There is no
better way to do it than using active
inference by extending generative models
of individual agents to account for the
beliefs and goals of other agents.
This is akin to theory of mind. It
enables them to anticipate and adapt to
the actions of their peers by offloading
to the group. So we
discussed a little bit's earlier shared
goals. Potential goals are
future oriented objectives that
individuals or groups strive to achieve.
They're not just mere desires, but
they're actively pursued through the act
of will that we called earlier fiat.
The fulfillment of a pretension drives
the agent towards a teleology that trail
set. We discussed the fulfillment of a
prediction entails less surprise and
therefore the agent self evidences. By
seeking to accurately predict their
surroundings, agents select a series of
actions or policies which generate
transitions between states that produce
expected observations. So through the
choice of policy, an individual can
reach their potented goal by minimizing
the expected free energy that a given
policy affords them. This seems pretty
central and simple in terms of active
inference. So farther potentials are
represented by the policies of longer
time death. In a hierarchical model,
this corresponds to a policy tied to a
higher level action in a slower
timescale. The choice of policies driven
by the expected free energy of that
higher order policy or the entire
multiscale generative model is based on
the agent's preferences, allowing an
agent to conduct gold directed behaviors
across temporal scales.
So this is where we can cash out Jeff
Yoshimi's trail sets where agents
assimilate actions into the anticipated
continuity of objects in their
surrounding world. This simulation
ensures a smoother understanding of the
environment and helps agents adapt
effectively. Near potentials act as
the near present contextual. Proximity
and the far pretensions rely on passive
synthesis of deontic cues which are
sedimented retentions in the
environment. The preferences
of the agents aligned by policies
correspond to attracting sets which in
the sociocognitive setting can be
instantiated as narratives. Having
shared narrative is a necessary aspect
of any exchange between artifacts,
people, institutions that have some kind
of attracting set generalized
synchrony which we will discuss a little
bit later as well. So a team working on
a project has a potential goal to
complete the project successfully. The
shared narrative might be the project
plan that guides their actions. It's
like everyone in the team has a shared
story about what they're trying to
achieve and how they're going to do it.
The relationship between current states
and future observations is captured
within the B matrix transitions. This
matrix represents the probability of
transitioning to a new state based on
the current state. So the B matrix
transition and the A matrix is utilized
to determine which new observations is
most likely to occur given the current
state and potential transitions. In the
Cerulean framework, the expectation
gradient structure plays a crucial role
in defining the depth and fulfillment of
pretensions. This structure
represents the varying degrees of
certainty and confidence agents have
in their predictions about future
states. The topology thus and
the arrangements is interrelation.
Sorry. There is an interrelation between
the potentials or the arrangements of
future expectations which is
proportional to the expectation
gradient. The higher the gradient, the
more detailed and accurate the
potentials are likely to be. The
potential horizon represents thus the
static states of the expected futures of
the temporal object while the
continuation horizon is the amalgamated
trail of the temporal object. Potential
and continuation horizons are carried in
protensions while the imminent horizon
consists of the primal impressions.
So agents can coordinate through
coconstruction where agents or
individuals interact and collaborate to
build this shared understanding and
shared goals. This process is deeply
interconnected within a complex web
where agents typically coexist with
other agents or subjects forming
a collective often referred to as
multiagent groups, swarm ensembles or
Samblage. By aligning their beliefs to
the signal found within their niche they
can better adapt to the environment and
develop a shared understanding of their
surroundings.
Sharing information with other agents is
beneficial as it allows them to trust
one another and pool their resources.
This collaborative approach is
preferable to a conflict driven scenario
in which every other agent is perceived
as a potential source of risk and
surprising. By sharing information
agents could collectively construct a
more accurate representation of their
environment leading to more effective
decision making and action. Through
these interactions, shared narratives
and goals can emerge from a
coconstruction of the world and each
agent's generative model. So these
narratives and goals are the result of
dynamic process that in fact can be
mathematically modeled through the
equations that we introduce in the paper
that this presentation is based on but
that I will present a little bit later.
They capture the process of mutual
learning where agents adapt their
generative model based on the
information gathered from their
interactions with others. Agents may
start off with slightly or greatly
divergent generative model. So in order
to minimize surprise there will be a
natural alignment within a group as
agents adapt to the evolving dynamics of
their environment and social contexts.
For example, again, consider this team
working on the project. Even if you have
your own understanding of the model or
of the project you'll interact and share
information and learn from each other
and then adapt the model. Over time,
you'll develop a shared understanding of
the project and a shared goal for its
completion. This is an instance of
coconstruction. It's like building a
house together where everyone
contributes to the final structure. The
emergence of shared narratives and the
learning and recognition of them may be
made more efficient through certain
mechanisms such as language. In an
experiment illustrated in a paper that
Karl Rozan two agents share the same
sensorium ask each other's questions. I
think it's a paper on 20 questions and
Emma Holmes with a shared narrative
entailing a common language. This
illustrates the marked efficiency and
the minimization of free energy simply
by having a shared language, a common
ground. So shared
potentials are common future
anticipations or goals that emerge among
groups of individuals through
coconstruction. It allows them to better
anticipate each other's actions and
intentions and work towards a common
goal. It's strongly tied to
the conscious efforts of individuals to
work towards that goal and to
effectively create an organizational
structures where we're engaged in a
conversation in an exchange assuming
that this exchange is meant to align our
generative models. So think of for
instance, a football team. Again, they
have a shared potential to win the
match. They anticipate each other's
moves and adapt their strategies based
on the ongoing game. Everyone in the
team has a shared vision of victory and
they're constantly adjusting their
actions to make it happen.
So individuals infer each other's mental
states by observing cues which they can
attribute to hidden causes. They use
their own model or models that they have
learned to recognize about others. This
process is known as generalized
synchrony entailing mutual
predictability, and can be interpreted
as a collective minimization of free
energy. In a group setting,
individuals create cues in the world
that direct other agents attentions
towards the same signals. Their models
of the world align by sharing similar
goals and similar environments and by
reinforcing patterns of sampling
reality. So we
could try to represent this through
polynomials and morphisms. Each agent's
interaction with the environment
corresponds to a morphism, and the
collective interaction of all agents can
be represented as a polynomial.
So if a polynomial p
is defined, morphism between two
polynomials, p and q, consists of a pair
of functions, f and g, such that f maps
p of one to q of one and
g maps P of I to q of the quantity one.
This morphism must satisfy the
commutative requirements, meaning that
the following diagram commutes p
of I maps to q of the quantity I and p
of one maps to q of one. So we could
see how we could create a framework to
further explore the cooperative and
competitive dynamics among agents. For
multiple agents indexed by I with
boundaries p and share environment
boundary q, their interaction can be
represented by a morphism of
polynomials, which allows us to
understand the shared potential in
multiagent systems and provides a
foundation for further exploration of
cooperative dynamics.
We allow each agent to predict not only
its own behavior, but also the behavior
of its companions and the environment's
response to their actions. So the
dynamics of shared predictions are
really useful here and can be properly
cashed out mathematically through
recursive cognition and prediction on
the shared environment of the agent's
actions and response to each other's
actions. We can use sheep's theoretic
and topos theoretical approaches to
understand multi agent systems. A multi
agent system is a system where multiple
individuals or entities interact. So for
example, a traffic system can be
considered a multi agent system where
different vehicles interact. A topos is
a category that has both spatial and
logical structure, allowing for the
expression of logical propositions and
deductions within it. So we can use
these approaches to construct a coherent
understanding of the world from the
perspective of multiple agents. The
internal universe of agents, which can
be seen as mathematical objects
containing beliefs, perceptions and
predictions of individual agents, are
represented using topoi.
These internal universes provide a
foundation for understanding and
representing the complex interactions
and shared understanding among multiple
agents in this dynamic environment.
We try to construct a consensus topos by
patching together the internal universes
or topoi of multiple agents. And the
idea is to use the sheep theoretic and
topos theoretic structures to build a
shared understanding.
So we can thus derive the
synchronization of goal oriented actions
among agents over time and leverage
mathematical insights for category
theory and generalized generative
models. This connection is the mechanism
through which the group synchronizes
over time and ultimately achieves their
objective. Agents within the system
might possess varying levels of
certainty in achieving the objective.
Some may choose to expend less energy,
temporarily decelerating their progress
towards the desired outcome. This
variation in certainty and approach
leads to the emergence of different
roles within a group, with some agents
focusing on computational tasks while
other monitor outcomes or engage in
different actions themselves. The nested
and distributed structure of generative
models in active inference allows for
the integration of both short term and
long term goals. Agents with similar
compatible preferences can coordinate
their actions by aligning their policies
and working towards common narratives.
So this alignment reduces the overall
expected free energy of their joint
actions, increasing the likelihood of
achieving shared goals and facilitating
the sharing of goals and expectation
among group members.
They can learn, which allows them to
learn essential role in shaping agents
preferences and strategies. Over time,
agents can gather new experiences and
update their generative model. They
refine their preferences and methods for
achieving goals. They can influence the
formation and modification of shared
narratives by having different
perspective over different parts of a
goal. Here,
the concept of generalized synchrony is
manifested when all agents have learned
compatible or harmonized aspects of the
overall generative model. The
synchronization is rooted in the
retentional and potential dynamics of
agents and can be more accurately
described using mathematical models.
So, in conclusion, we tried to shed
light on the concept of shared potential
goals and multiagent systems. We've
emphasized the importance of
understanding this concept as it plays a
crucial role in the coordination
synchronization of agents actions and
intentions. We in the future
continuously highlight the role of cues
in the environment and how they can be
simple like marks on the road or more
complex like symbols and language. The
queues become carriers of passive
synthesis, far pretensions and far
retention, and become ways to minimize
free energy as they minimize the amount
of any individual has to compute. It
also allows us to delve into the concept
of other evidencing in which the
environment is in effect the self and
others must learn to navigate
in terms of others and self.
We've provided mathematical models to an
equations to analyze dynamics of shared
potentials more accurately. In terms of
category theory, we've explored the
dynamics of shared retentions and
potentials in hierarchical generative
models which reflect the complex
interplay of individual and collective
dynamics. We've encapsulated the
structure of time consciousness and how
this allows agents to co compute shared
potentials by mapping each other's
cognitive pathways.
So our approach basically begins an
examination of hospital temporal
phenomenology integrated with a
hierarchical active inference model,
polynomial morphisms and home
polynomials. This enables recursive
cognition and prediction of not only an
agent's actions, but also the
environment's response to these actions.
So I think this comes to the end,
Daniel. I think I'm literally at 30
minutes. Thank you,
impeccable. Thank you, Mahault it.
Yeah, great presentation. Awesome topic.
So thank you for joining and looking
forward to seeing how the work continues
to develop.